hi guys today's video is show you how to
program a Nissan key fob and the key
this is a flip style key first you're
gonna have to get your key cut I'm going
to cut my myself but if you guys don't
know how to cut a key and get it off the
internet or something then just take it
to your nearest Walmart or Lowe's or
somewhere like that that will cut the
key for you the reason you're gonna have
to have the key cut first is because
when you go to program your key fob you
have to have your key munition and you
have to turn your key and it was not cut
yet that is not going to turn your
nishan so I'm gonna go do that first
guys if you cut your key you want to
make sure that it fits in your lock then
actually turns both ways locks and
unlocks and then one check your initial
okay guys what you want to do is make
sure your doors lock put your key and
now nishan mine takes about 12 or 13
times once that clicks you put the key
back in you turn it to acessories and
then you click the lock letting you take
a key back out and lock the door you
open the door and you check the key
problem all right now let's program the
key all right guys on this next part all
the keys you have to program this car
you're gonna want to have on hand -
three so gonna want to make sure you
have the keys that you program into the
car on hand so what you good do is we're
gonna be using the CKD 100 and a Nissan
automatic pincode so what I do want to
do
go ahead and get this all set up I'm
gonna go down to where it says get the
glare off the teeth thing where it says
pincode services so I'm gonna go down to
their raincoat services then try to put
this for both and see it I'm going to
click enter and then I'm gonna go down
to Nissan BCM code you saw BCM code I'm
gonna click enter again and I'm gonna
turn on the ignition and then I'm gonna
click inner again enter one last time
and then I have my pink code right there
so now I'm going to back out of that and
I'm going to go up to immobilize your
system and I'm gonna click enter on the
immobilizer I'm gonna go all the way
down to Nissan Xterra alright so once we
get down to Nissan Xterra we're gonna
choose Nissan or my med Nissan USA not
Nissan Xterra so we're gonna click
Nissan USA and then I'm gonna go down to
Nissan Xterra cuz that's what this
vehicle is
okay now we have Nissan Xterra and
Nissan Xterra the top one is 2003 to
2004 and the bottom one is 2005 to 2007
so I'm gonna go to 2005 to 2007 because
this is an O 7 and then you also got
another Nissan Xterra that's from 2008
to 2014 but ours is 2007 so I'm going to
click 2007 click enter that tells me how
many tokens it's going to use I click
enter it asks with gas or diesel I'm
going to click gas then it says turn on
a Nishan nisshin's already on somebody
to click enter and I'm gonna click 2 on
that and then just lets me know that I'm
going to need the pin code to do this
service I'm going to click ok because I
understand that and then then it asks
for the pin code so I'm going to put in
the pin code 4 7 1 once I get my pin
code entered go ahead and click enter
click enter again
and then turn off click okay and now it
says to put the keys in turn to the on
position not the start position but the
on position within five seconds of each
key so I'm the last key you gonna put in
you started B equals rounding so I'm
going to click enter ask if I want to
save the whatever I'm gonna click now
and I'm done and now let's test out all
the keys make sure they're working this
one
sorry something vehicle next key starts
up the vehicle Laskey it starts up the
vehicle so now we got the key fob
programmed and the key program to start
vehicle well we're done
hopefully this can help thank you guys
for watching like always don't forget to
Like and subscribe if you haven't
watched my other videos go through them
and watch them I will leave a link down
below on where you can get the CK 100
and ningke's on pin code reader it
actually converts the BCM code to pin
code so you can actually program the
keys what it does so thank you guys for
watching